that and stephen i'm sorry there's uh  there's more there's more people list  more companies there's more on the list  there's a couple more it's a longer list  if you'll oh okay the page uh that's  right i have it also listed viacom cbs  the 1953 trust roc nation robert kelly  david boyes milton brown nypd  and sony and sony moving on  i i hate to say this but i mean it  really is kind of like the whole world  how many people have been involved with  underage sex trafficking i uh it's a  secret there's more  a little more  not a lot i'm sure yeah all right okay  so also named in the lawsuit u.s versus  jelaine maxwell the uh the the uh the  assistant to jeffrey epstein who helped  rape countless underage women uh def jam  recordings marcelo clare virgil a blow  parkwood entertainment sir philip green  black cube ltd terence thornton vivendi  essay um i don't know note that the the  civil suit was dismissed on standing  kind of like the election lawsuits